i i know i ought not to be here
the dark lord himself forbade me to
speak of this
[Music]
actress helen mccrory has died she was
52 years old
helen's husband billions actor damian
lewis revealed the sad news on instagram
friday
writing in a touching post quote i'm
heartbroken to announce
that after a heroic battle with cancer
the beautiful and mighty woman that is
helen mccrory
has died peacefully at home damian went
on to praise his late wife for living
fearlessly and acknowledged how lucky he
feels to have had her
in his life quote she blazed so brightly
damien and helen married in 2007 and
shared two kids together
fourteen-year-old daughter manon and
thirteen-year-old son
gulliver in a 2011 interview with the
evening standard
damien shared a heartwarming tradition
between the couple
after his proposal to helen in paris was
interrupted by tourists
they started taking annual trips back to
the city of lights every february
without their kids for their anniversary
helen was known for her role in the
harry potter franchise as draco malfoy's
mom
narcissa you should be honored [ __ ] i
should drink her
he's just a boy she also starred in the
series peaky blinders
mr shelby asked me to tell you that he's
busy with the catering preparation
and while you're waiting we have aprium
cocaine
and brandy and penny dreadful i needn't
remind you of the consequences of
disloyalty
need i
i just can't imagine what the museum
governors would make of them
you